herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
16 Jahre das haben wir mal für sie
ausgerechnet mit dem Taschenrechner das
sind
5800 Tage und knapp
140.000 Stunden solange war
Bundeskanzlerin Angela Merkel im Amt ja
und wir schauen noch mal drauf auf so
ein paar Schlagzeilen die sie gemacht
hat in der Zeit ja in Wahrheit eine Zeit
voller Schlagzeilen Miss Germany so fing
das alles an und mit einem
optimistischen Blick irgendwie Zukunft
und dann wurde es mit der Zeit aber auch
mal härter am Anfang noch privat werden
gefragt bei der Vereidigung wo war
eigentlich der Joachim Sauer saß damals
nicht auf der Tribüne später hat sie es
dann erklärt oder war in der Zeit und
dann ging es eben langsam los die ersten
Dienstreisen für die Kanzlerin und dann
wie gesagt wann irgendwann die 100 Tage
die Schonzeit vorbei jobkrise erstmal
dann das Gerangel in den eigenen Reihen
die die gestänkert haben dahinter die
Roland Koch sie Friedrich Merz und so
weiter und so fort und es ging durch
flüchtlingskrise durch Finanzkrise durch
bis heute zur Corona Krise und wir
wollen Bilanz ziehen hier bei Bild live
und das wollen wir tun mit Alex von
Schönburg der zu uns gekommen ist zu
petlife Morgen Kai Morgen Patricia
eigentlichen also gut gehalten hatte
sich schonmal oder sehen Sie ich meine
es ist ja auch nicht das ist ja auch ein
Job der
ziemlich viel Stress
zur Folge hat und dann würde ich nie
Feierabend hast und dafür finde ich
wirkt sie
eigentlich nicht eigentlich ziemlich fit
und man kann dir das jetzt wirklich
gönnen und ich glaube ihr das auch
wirklich wenn sie sagt sie will jetzt
erstmal ausschlafen und genießt genießt
die Zeit im leeren Kanal Terminkalender
zu haben da muss man sich erstmal
gewöhnen
Termine Termine nicht aufstehen müssen
lange um wahrscheinlich so sagen wie es
ist jetzt tatsächlich ein anderes neues
Leben aber wenn ich auch wissen wie
schaut dieses andere neue Leben aus und
dass wir wissen von Ralf Schuler er ist
unser Merkel Reporter kann man wirklich
sagen ist der Kanzlerin also Seite
jahrelang auf den Fersen und hat sie ja
begleitet ist uns jetzt zugeschaltet und
auch Angelika Hellemann ist bei uns auch
weil sie unsere Scholz Reporterin hat
heute auch schon die Pressekonferenz die
Koalition zu unterzeichnen für uns
verfolgt ihr beide seid uns jetzt
zugeschaltet wenn es Ihr da seid reif
als erstes wollen wir wissen was macht
die Kanzlerin jetzt wohl mit ihrer
freien Zeit wo wir sie die nächsten
Stunde bewusst die nächsten Tage
verbringen
also zunächst mal ist sie bis zum
Anschlag bis zur letzten Stunde dass
Olaf Scholz das Catan übernimmt ist sie
im Amt sie hat gestern abend noch mal
mit beiden makron mit Johnson und
Italiens Ministerpräsidenten telefoniert
umhin der ukraine-krise ad-hoc doch noch
irgendwelche gemeinsamen Standpunkte zu
finden für Europäer und amerikanische
Verbündete also da gehen die
Amtsgeschäfte wirklich bis zum Schluss
auszuräumen im Büro ist nicht viel da
waren ohnehin nicht viel private
Gegenstände drin die Bilder gehören der
dem staatlichen kunstarchiv nimm ein
foto mit nach Hause von Helmut Kohl ein
sehr anrührende sehr nah aufgenommenes
Foto in Portrait und sie hat in den
letzten Tagen die Bücher verschenkt die
sie noch im Büro hatte und jeder der
vorbeikam konnte sich welche aussuchen
Horst Seehofer beispielsweise hat sich
den Band die hohe Kunst der Politik von
Annette Schavan herausgegeben über die
Ära Merkel mitgenommen und sie soll er
sollte auswählen zwischen
Lichtgeschwindigkeit dem Buch der
biontech Erfinder na
dann wird es langsam sein und Angela
Merkel wird dann bis morgen 15 Uhr noch
im Amt sein und danach freut sie sich
tatsächlich auf einmal ausschlafen
vielleicht mal das lesen was man lesen
will und sie hat schon angedeutet dass
sie auch die eine oder andere
Schirmherrschaft vielleicht übernehmen
will die ihr ein Anliegen ist aber das
alles Zeit man kann ihr das glaube ich
auch glauben dass
politischer Übereifer in der Rente nicht
ihr Problem ist aber total irre
eigentlich nach 16 Jahren nach so langer
Zeit das ist das
ja vielmehr kann man da auch nicht
mitnehmen sie hat ja sehr viele
Geschenke bekommen die man als
Amtsträger bekommt er hat beispielsweise
Kompriband im Verband der privaten
Waldbesitzer jedes Jahr eine etwa ein
Meter große hölzerne Schachfigur
geschenkt bekommen hat als fast schon
ein Spiel zusammen was soll man damit
als Privatmann man darf ist ohnehin
nicht mitnehmen dann könnte es raus
kaufen das kommt dann alles in die
Asservatenkammer und wird irgendwann
versteigert und Olaf Scholz liegt dann
einen neuen Vorrat an Amt beschenken an
Olaf Scholz hatte in seinem Büro im
Finanzministerium
großformatige Bauhaus
Fotografien der ist großer Bauhaus fänd
das könnte sein dass er die mitnimmt
aber wie das Büro des künftigen Kanzlers
aussieht darum wird noch ein großes
Geheimnis gemacht er wird schon
versuchen einen anderen Stil zu prägen
und zu dem Büro sein eigenen Stempel
aufdrücken zumal er tatsächlich großes
Interesse auch für Architektur hat aber
wie es dann aussieht da müssen wir uns
noch überraschen lassen gibt's da so in
der Art Masterplan Angelika weil das
wird ja nicht allzu vielen deutschen
zuteil dass man den ersten Tag im
Kanzleramt erleben darf den ersten Tag
im kanzlerbüro dass man überhaupt weiß
was mache ich da als erstes wiege läuft
das mit dem Umzug und so weiter also
gibt's dafür Masterplan Scholz wer
kümmert sich da drum
es gibt ganz ganz viele Mitarbeiter im
Hintergrund die das gerade organisieren
was Scholz jetzt gerade selbst machen
muss er wird heute erst noch eine
Pressekonferenz hier in der
Bundespressekonferenz geben zusammen mit
Christian Lindner und Robert Habeck und
heute Nachmittag ist Fraktionssitzung
und das ist für Scholz auch wieder was
Neues denn er ist jetzt Mitglied der
Fraktion erst auch ganz normaler
Bundestagsabgeordneter erst in Potsdam
angetreten hat dort das Direktmandat
gewonnen übrigens gegen Annalena
baerbock vorher als Finanzminister war
er zwar Teil der Regierung aber eben
nicht Teil des Parlamentes und er will
ja am Mittwoch gewählt werden das heißt
das ist eine geheime Wahl da will er
dann alle Stimmen aller Abgeordneten
haben der Ampelkoalition das heißt da
wird er auch noch mal für sich werben
und dann muss er halt weiter planen die
Minister stehen jetzt fest die
Staatssekretäre also die da drunter noch
nicht und da muss jetzt noch ganz viel
an Personal und hergeschoben werden so
langsam ist klar wen er aus dem
Finanzministerium rüber nimmt z.b. seine
Büroleiterin und die nehmen dann auch
wieder Kontakt mit der alten Regierung
auf und die sind sozusagen im ständigen
Kontakt um eine möglichst reibungslose
Amtsübergabe zu übernehmen eines der
größten Zeichen wie sie zusammenarbeiten
war ja auch dass Angela Merkel und Olaf
Scholz zusammen beim G20 Gipfel in Rom
waren sie als Kanzlerin als
Finanzminister und dort eigentlich schon
alle Gespräche zusammengeführt haben
also wir versuchen gerade hier zu zeigen
wie Machtübergabe in einer Demokratie
abläuft nämlich ohne Streit sondern eben
mit Akzeptanz des Wahlergebnisses also
wir fassen zusammen Angela Merkel räumt
große Schachfiguren in den Keller und
Olaf Scholz hat derzeit noch anderes zu
tun als sich darum zu kümmern wo die
Bauhaus Kunst dann hängen wird Angela
Hellemann und Ralf Schuler vielen
herzlichen Dank euch für die Information
Herr Schlagzeilen Expertenmeinungen das
haben wir jetzt alles gehört wie Angela
Merkel in den vergangenen Jahren
wahrgenommen wurde aber das wichtigste
der wichtigste Spiegel ihrer an Zeit das
sind sie das ist das Volk Was bleibt bei
ihnen von 16 Jahren Kanzlerin Merkel
hängen und Reporter waren in ganz
Deutschland unterwegs und genau das zu
erfahren Sie sich 16 Jahre lang in einer
Männerdomäne behaupten und ich denke
dort schon was dazu ich fand sie hat
auch die Jugendlichen so verstanden sie
hat auch sowas für die Jugendlichen
getan als sie hat uns so rein integriert
das mit dem Atomausstieg total 8
2015 war die Entscheidung wo ich mich an
für sich auch dazu bewogen hat steht sie
will muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen
[Gelächter]
für Leben alles gute noch und so wie sie
es gemacht hat die letzten 16 Jahre war
schon gut muss ich wirklich sagen
hätte man besser machen können aber
von Merkel alles Gute
alles Gute für die Zukunft
Angela Merkel doch gar nicht so gut da
wie man das jetzt nach 16 Jahren
Amtszeit vielleicht zuerst einmal
empfindet in der aktuellen Corona Krise
sagen nämlich immer noch 52% von ihnen
das hat sie eher schlecht gemacht und
nur 24% sind da richtig positiv gestimmt
Eurokrise Riesenthema natürlich in ihrer
Amtszeit Euro und Finanzkrise
36% jeweils sagen das hat sie nicht so
gut gemanagt und ebenso viel sagen von
ihnen doch doch das hat Angela Merkel
schon gut gemacht also hier eine
gespaltene Meinung unter den deutschen
Rentenpolitik da gibt's die meisten
unzufriedenen das war ja auch ein Wal
entscheidendes Thema tatsächlich jetzt
bei der Bundestagswahl viele haben sich
auch deswegen für Scholz entschieden und
tatsächlich mehr als jeder zweite
Deutsche sagt wenn man intensiver nachts
fragt also mit der Rentenpolitik von
Angela Merkel sind wir nicht so
zufrieden und jetzt das Entscheidende
Thema das große Thema in der Amtszeit
Merkels in den Jahren 215 216 war
natürlich flüchtlingskrise hier sagt nur
rund jeder vierte Deutsche die hat sie
richtig gut gemanagt und 53 % der
Deutschen sind da nach wie vor
unzufrieden flüchtlingskrise nicht auf
der Habenseite bei Angela Merkel da
sagen doch mehr als jeder zweite
Deutsche nein nein das ist nicht gut
gelaufen in der Marke Regierung
ach das ist schon lange
sie war
kurz in
Brüssel
ja das für dich so sagen wo in Romania
Menschen die so oft nicht trifft aber
immerhin regelmäßig trifft nicht
wirklich durchleuchten er kann aber sie
ist eine Frau obwohl ruhig gefasst
die Dinge Einhorn and the Auftretens
jemanden gewesen immer gewesen der auch
zu
Emotionen fähig seit
wann sie an
[Musik]
sie
beeindruckt durch Bescheidenheit auch im
privaten Chat
mit der
ausgetauscht und ihre Mutter starb erst
an Eltern starben da haben wir über die
eigentlich wichtigen Dinge des Lebens so
miteinander geredet
auswählen Teile derselben Familie ich
habe sie sehr gemocht
es wirklich
sehr sehr gut kennengelernt haben
wir noch mal zurück
[Musik]
diasorin nie mit der Faust auf den Tisch
grau das haben Regierungschefs und auch
einen Staatschef immer weh getan
das braucht sie nicht sie musste nicht
dick auftragen
weil ihre Anwesenheit hat schon dazu
beigetragen tut er Arten Weise wie der
verstorben anderen zuzuhören das bei ihr
viele Dinge zusammen ich habe ich
natürlich auch
das auch schicken sofort zu entscheiden
ob Europa insgesamt tun gut getan sowie
sie überhaupt Europa gut getan hat weil
sie hat es geschafft
und auch gewollt aber nicht gestand
Europäischen Union inklusive der
Kommission das gleiche Augen zu schenken
zuzuhören sodass sich alle im letzten
letztendlich
mit ihren Hoffnungen Ihren Wünschen mit
ihrer Kritik bei ihr indem sie sich ohne
Kompromisse bemühte aufgehoben
war schon gut was die alles in Europa
geschafft hat sie hat Europa gut getan
sag Jean-Claude Juncker sie hat der Welt
gut getan Peter Altmaier war am Sonntag
hier bei Bild und hat gesagt sie hat es
geschafft dass Deutschland in der Welt
geliebt wird und dann gab es auf diesen
Satz ganz viele Reaktion vor allen
Dingen im Osten Deutschland wo man
gesagt hat aber wir haben sie irgendwie
nicht lieben gelernt also gerade in
Ostdeutschland im Zuge der Eurokrise vor
allen Dingen im Zuge der
flüchtlingskrise gibt es auch sehr sehr
viel Abneigung wie erklären sich bis
heute diese tiefe Abneigung dir auch in
der Gründung und dem Erfolg einer Partei
gemündet ist der AFD
[Musik]
flüchtlingskrise weniger gut gelöst
wurden werden und die ersten größten
Problemen im gesamte Mitteleuropa zu tun
gehabt hat insofern muss man diese
Meinungsumfragen auch mehr aus dem
Angriff genommen ihr Hirten zu bringen
also ich habe heute morgen noch zufällig
mit dir telefoniert sie ihrem nächsten
Lebensabschnitt
mit
organisierter Gefasstheit Geli ist ja
ausreichen um Schluss nicht mehr zur
Wahl angetreten und Soße war vielleicht
ein anderes Ergebnis
hatte ich glaube sie wird jetzt ein paar
Monate
Ruhepause einlegen Ruhe hat sie verdient
war sehr überrascht
hektisches Leben
führt es reicht jetzt sie hat Ruhe
fertig
außer ich breche nie aus persönlichen
Gesprächen wir haben uns aus Freude
gegen danke herzlich für das Gedanken
herzlichen Dank tschüss